it
almost s
Felipe what's up F podcast before we
start let me make sure there's no
Pokemons to be looking for in the
studio cuz I got to get one man but the
the internet here sucks so yeah I you
know what on the way over here I saw one
in the car it was sitting on Lisa's lap
and um my [__] phone froze ah so that
it was a rabbit so that just all he did
was just going over and over it was a
rabbit yeah I haven't seen that one yet
it pink a what so F podcast with Felipe
spa and back by popular demand and we
sent Rodrigo back to sakas Mexico we got
Dustin iara DUS hey what's up guys he's
the human wrecking ball I am
dude dude yeah man this K talk about
being kidnapped bro I'm the human re we
went back to do the pitch meeting the
pitch meeting right up yeah yeah we uh
we went over all that yesterday do you
want to deconstruct what happened
yesterday I don't know bro I I don't
care man well let me show you show up
[__] up already was I that [__] was it
obvious man cuz I was wondering did
Peter know like that I was [__] up you
think n nobody knew man Peter he was too
he was on the side of you so he didn't
see in front of you so you oh God you
didn't see my crazy eyeballs and [__] I
saw your crazy eyeballs okay plus you
were eded on too much I was what I know
D once I did you see how I tried to get
away from though remind me of anybody
anybody read a book called permanent
midnight by Jerry stall and rent the
movie it stars um Ben Steeler as Jerry
stall and he plays a guy who was a rider
for Al and um 30 something and you can
see how this guy will come in [__]
cracked out to right Al yeah I wasn't
cracked out really no man just saying
that yeah what happened though I was it
you know Ben Glee he's got like a pool
and I went over there earlier so I was
day drinking and that was me love pool
out there huh I said mexan love pool
don't belong to them oh my God yes bro
that's how I know like I'm like I'm he's
my best friend bro the pool yeah dude so
I was hanging out over there and then so
I was dream
and I then I was like oh crap I got a
meeting to get to so then I know you
called me all late I did yeah you know
what you know it's funny man like when
Dustin de called me and I made that call
before I know we have our guest here Ed
edro yo what's up you know man you know
he know I'm pretty sure he made that
phone call too I made that phone call
that phone call you make like 30 minutes
before a movie but you're calling in a
voice that you're expecting them to say
it got
canceled
I just want to get invited to the pool
dude I couldn't remember if we were
meeting or not I was like is it today is
it tomorrow when are we meeting and then
my phone was dying and I was all drunk I
was like what am I doing and so anyway I
know what you're talking about I did add
on too much cuz I remember like my first
time I was
like I I don't know if I would say and I
was like listen I know you guys are
really professional you've been doing it
your whole lives you get paid we're
gonna go where you guys go go your way
yeah it was so ridiculous so then after
that you want it kept going yeah after
that we kept going um actually during
the meeting there's always um um there's
always um when we're there at um at um
Bobby Bowman's house if you're listening
out there does he have a pool Bobby
Bowman no he doesn't have a pool that's
why we don't hang out as much he has a
dog that's blind and deaf
damn I'm afraid if I look at that dog
wrong it's just going to die oh man wait
did I just see that you guys got a
rabbit yeah or a bunny we do have a
rabbit if you're anybody's inquiring on
my Snapchat Felipe spa and Lisa from the
in of the castle R podcast we do have a
rabbit we have we rescue that
[__] really
$60 no Lisa was on Craigslist we had
another pet Andro we had a we had a
hamster okay all right peace Chucky that
was the first time I cried for an animal
wow I heard you say R right peace did
did he die in pieces yeah he died dog
show he showed up bro like Lisa took
fell asleep with with her hamster cuz it
was already dying his her last days of
chilling you know she was under the
blanket and when Lisa woke up she goes
Chucky died right when I said no I want
to go punch the first person I saw
outside I want to do that how long how
long man did Chucky last eight months
oh Dam yeah so um just natural causes
when she was natural she was there man
laying down and look like a [__]
crack [__] dead dog like she was all
blue and red little [__] U Coke nose
coming out of her real blood oh poor
little thing we buried him outside put
him in a little bag little cross little
cross you don't know was religion what
if he
was like we had fish that had died but
we didn't were like cry no okay but our
our son you know Isaac Hayes Miko he was
sad when our our fish died yeah he he
put a little
r a little [__] Tombstone how long
have you guys had the bunny um we had
four months four months oh wow we had a
three months we travel with it sneak to
hotels yeah I had a guinea pig one time
and my mom left it in the car and it
died [__] yeah I till this day I I'm
like Mom why'd you do that are you
serious you killed my best friend we
just got a pug a Puggle half Pug half
beagle and uh bet that's I I was trying
to talk my boss out of it and [__] that
man who's the one has a clean up after
this piece of [__] I'm not I'm not a big
fan I'm not
a wow man we went to the Improv last
time we went to the impro you know what
funny I I normally like I'm out of town
you know and um I travel a lot so s of
edro right here so we hardly ever go out
and when we do go out to the Laugh
Factory it's noticable that we were out
like people say oh we saw Eddie and
Peters you know you Noti you went out so
I it's been a minute man and how often
do you show up at the clubs now never
how crazy is that and that's where I
always used to see you that's where we
always used to hang out to go three
times a show bro damn and if I like if
the line was long I'll just [__]
leave and go to another club and then
close it out at the Mexican clubs cuz
they were dancing
there dancing so I go to the Improv and
um Liza schlinger performing yeah and I
walk in there with [__] long hair
it's funny when you walk in with another
long hair you notice there's long hair
[__] in the room I know we just
look like Ruffians and just like what
are these trou are these guys causing we
came in like we were like two like if
you don't know who we are um Dustin iara
iara iar I or velia I whoa that's too
much and did you see bro my maras came
out yeah man we're noticeable man to
Long ha guys a little short Mexican fool
F mexan fo Hollywood bro and it's
different they have the lab now it it is
a little weird uh the is there three
rooms or two two upstairs they do
podcasting yeah oh dude I ran into
that's another last night I ran into
this fool this comic from like way back
in the day when I lived in New York and
he didn't remember me bald fool yeah
John Roy yeah and I was like hey what's
up man he's like uh what I'm like fo
Dustin man come on don't act like I've
changed my
look doing a podcast or something yeah
yeah they were doing that upstairs I met
him one time cuz I had a show called Tor
tortilla no tequila Tuesdays at the BR
and I booked John Roy to do it one time
and he's from Chicago and he walked out
to me a long time ago and said um my dad
is is a fan of your comedy it's funny I
lot these white Comics their fans their
dads are fans of my comedy wow did so
did you go up last night hell no man it
was like a long ass Line open micers oh
really I didn't feel it man yeah I
didn't I ended up not going up last
night either what happened you passed
out with JC's room you want to hear what
happened man what happened do first of
all this F loud man you dropped man I
dropped the for the laptop at the LA
Factory and took off we were sell a car
man I said [__] it man we're driving to
the Improv from this Fool's house Bobby
Bowman and um I turned on my phone to
look for Pokemons and D yelling out the
window man like no he's really yelling
out the window yeah any Pokemon here and
and then
and you could talk with a [__]
enough from M cuz he's Ying like [__]
cholos yeah I'm like you guys see any
Pokemon here we don't get with those K
oh wait Dustin now now your name Rings
about you were supposed to be on a movie
set at our house uh I think like two
weeks ago no yeah and I had to do that
was for the uh that was that day we were
doing the uh three Arts thing oh right
that's right yeah I remember uh Joey the
director was like man he was he cancel
on me last minute you know what's funny
I I can bro I'll show you the shooting
schedule I not supposed to work until
later that day and I was like okay so in
the evening I'll just pop by and I I let
him know and he was like hey I need you
there like super early tomorrow and I'm
like whoa hold up man I got this meeting
at three yards I got to go to he's like
man you're
really I mean bro really like throwing a
wren in my whole operation I'm like bro
I mean come on I looked at the shooting
schedule and he was like telling me he's
like bro you got to be professional
about these things I'm like the shooting
schedule that's what I go by bro it's
like yeah I mean if you told you last
minute to show up in the morning then I
understand that dude yeah man that's Joy
Medina right yeah Joy Medina he shooting
his Pilot uh yeah I mean I was impressed
with the setup you know he even had
catering and everything so there's
there's there's a um a part of the the
pilot that U we read and it's kind of
like it's good it's funny it's really
funny but it's it's edgy yeah it's
hardcore when he bought when when um
when um when um I think when Joy Medina
brought his mom to Russell Peter's house
yeah that's a crazy ass Scene It Is the
bag yep so so you know Russell Russell
was in a couple scenes so that's a good
scene though it looks good it looks good
for a comedian who does who like who
like like at Joy Medina level My Level
to see like another comedian who's
successful it's hard to watch but it's
good
huh and then you bring your mom around
right the best description why would you
bring your mom around mom look this is
Success no [__] and this right here is
right me yeah and over here is Dustin
getting [__]
up oh yeah so anyway my pilot movie yeah
dude I went to the factory and like um
Steve is there big ass
Steve been a long time good to see you
man Chang here man wait when's the last
time you went to the Laugh Factory did
you go last night hope show oh so you
didn't go last night to the Laugh
Factory yeah I did oh yeah you Dro me
off though Chris Newberg had just gotten
off the stage killing it Tope so you
made your rounds last night I made my
rounds bro I went to everywhere except
The Comedy Store my next move so what's
up tonight let's go let's go tonight
what happened what happened bro okay so
I go in here's where it gets a little
bit blurry this is where I was
definitely the most [__] up of the
evening was the Laugh Factory and I I
just remember when I was choking you
with a Velvet Rope I don't even remember
that that sounds hilarious bro that
sounds great I I I dude I don't even
remember my [__] remember [__] up off of
what you choke me with a Velvet Rope
like it's a gagger for real what you get
[__] up on liquor beer what everything
um so I was there and um okay see
another like dude's always been like
ridiculously nice and he's so cool man
um io's like
heyoo no someone else was like Hey
you're not going up on the show tonight
and I'm like I'm like were you schedu
yeah yeah I was what happened when show
to fipe to a comedy club [__] loaded
did D cook show up or what no I just was
like she's like you're not going up and
I'm like so uh pull me outside we have a
big I go P me outside we're talking for
like a long time and she's like listen
doesn't I'm sorry you're you're great
guy we we love you you just know you're
a little [__] up right now and I'm
like man I should be up there on stage
killing right now instead of kidding in
the audience yeah now I'm I'm getting
all emotional and so st's like hey man
that never happened to me yeah he's like
dude don't man we all love you man just
you we don't want you to get B come on
man and I'm like whatever man so I'm
like so we end up walking down I believe
it okay was so it wasn't a scheduling
conflict it's cuz you were [__] up man
he was [__] loaded his was at 11:
[__] up at 9: yeah oh way before that
so we go so then we walked to The Comedy
Store the walk sobered me up a little
bit and I'm like that's how Mexican
Comics um Network by the way getting
[__] up with
other and um so I go to The Comedy Store
and over there you go to the comedy St
after all y [__] I should have stood
there my buddy Jordan's over there and
like we ended up hanging out and like
like Hannibal burish showed up man and
here's how I knew I was pretty [__] up
cuz we're were talking and stuff and he
was like Dustin man you're like you're
like being crazy and I'm like what are
you talking about he's like you just
like like what are you do man chill and
I'm like what you know so then I was
like I know a guy who hangs around with
um Eric Andre is telling you to
CH that is not good this guy has seen
[__] balls Bo a has seen balls to his
face tell to chill out he's telling you
to chill godamn he does a show with a
guy who [__] up a set yeah by the way
which I'm going to be on that show this
season
season season four season 4 and Hannibal
burs is played by a
robot nice two episodes man I'm there
with with Amber Rose really nice and
some basketball player and two course
from Breaking Bad really nice what
happened bro you lot of great cars last
night I did um
yeah my reputation man um yeah well no I
knew Hannibal from back in the day and
stuff so he was like everyone that I was
around last night knew me it wasn't like
I was just showing up like everyone knew
like Dustin's [__] up dude see I'm
glad I left you alone cuz they would
have saw you with me they would have
said he's doing crack too [__] Felipe
are bringing him down that's what they
went you got to get away from
influence they're on the way down no
this morning I what happened bro this
morning this morning I'm what happened
the laugh fact on the way out this more
my girlfriends okay yeah so talking to
you outside or inside where where we at
right now Laugh Factory Laugh Factory
when when they're telling you about man
you're [__] [__] up you're like a
wild animal yeah and so from there I'm
like whatever blah blah blah we just
walked down to uh The Comedy Store you
know going in there Hannibal's there all
those cats Nick's there um just Nick who
Gara open up for somebody there was a uh
but we yeah we just went in there and
that was just it was actually that's the
most [__] up I was was I'm guessing at
the Laugh Factory cuz everything after
that I remembered pretty good you know
what I'm saying I remember I remember
calling the Uber I remember like I
remember looking at everyone and
thinking like yeah I'm [__] up does
this happen on the regular uh
you know it's weird lately man I've been
doing to stand up for like like 12 years
man I started when I was like 16 I never
really drank or anything I don't know
last year has been just like I don't
know man so anyway I called the Laugh
Factory this morning and I talked to IO
I'm like listen I'm sorry I'm so sorry I
messed up I'm very sorry bro I'm I'm the
one who wrote that blog about B you by
the
way negative review on Yol did you read
that no I read that that was messed up
man it sound like a this gruntle unfunny
Open Mic that's what it sounds like yeah
and was emplo but if you ever worked at
the Laugh Factory you know it's not
really the manager's fault it goes
beyond all the way to the top shs no
yeah yeah you know what sucks about
stand up there's so many examples
getting a bad review
by a bad review by
anal did he give you what I still
remember the one bad review you did
at a hotel was it [__] that [__]
Rich dollar Victor dollar Victor dollar
forgot his name Victor dollar bro I got
into a fight at the sherton hotel are
you serious cuz I walked in there after
doing radio and I saw a buffet line and
I thought [__] it it's for everybody you
know yeah but didn't see that it was
belong to some a corporate event so then
but it was set up in the lobby right up
in the lobby and the manager told me put
that oatmeal down and I said [__] you
you who the [__] are you put that
oatmeal down if I had a gun I probably
have shot that [__] in the fo
cowboy style he still put that oal down
like I was a child and I said who the
[__] are
you then I said um he never answered who
he was he never answered who he was he
didn't St who he is so to me though he's
Hank Hill you know he's going to get
punched so then I put the oatmeal down I
put it down I put it dumb by your feet
so I put a dumb by his feet right in
front of his feet he made some he made
some house clean Pi pick her up oh
that's then I say I'm go say he goes
you're not used to dealing with a real
Mexican H [__] [__] you and I
went back to my room man he went back to
his office and I wrote a bad review on
his
ass you can probably still find it too
what's it's still on there bro got like
likes AO was cool though this morning
she was like Dustin we all love you um
you could come tonight you're you're a
good well I'm actually at the show I'm
on the show tonight I was I was I was
kind of making sure I wasn't banned you
know I was making sure I was still on
the show tonight she was like yeah it's
it's it's cool you know we just talked
we had a good heart to heart and I was
like you know talks about like comedy
Heart to Heart rasa bro yeah in comedy
you can almost see your future just cuz
you've seen so many Comics you know and
you're just like oh that's my path I'll
I'll do that and then I'll get sober and
then I'll you know you just see pH has
been through that [__] exactly yeah I
look at that and I'm like oh well and
Felipe among like countless other
Comedians and it's like well that's
probably what's going to happen yeah
yeah but the button gets hit several
times yeah
man button on your career oh yeah I know
and I can feel that that's what I can
dude yeah but that's how most Comics are
you know man like like right now you're
like dealing with um a lot of [__] in
your head you know your lady's
delivering food um [__] it you're
working on a pilot you know you're
[__] so stressed out about this [__]
we want I had s you had a show you
things working out you're on
Batman you know and now now is the
perfect time to destroy all this
[__] together right now you would do
this you wouldn't do this if you had
nothing going on if you have nothing
going on there's no point of getting
[__] upz there's nothing to destroy my
phip just said that sounds like a good
start man for how many years you're in
12 right that's impressive that's impr
you're in 12 yeah you're about the time
to destroy your career it's about the
time
right some people do it early like Dylan
Garcia oh no oh [__] do it too early
good example there good example bro but
Philipe I've seen you man yeah man that
was [__] God mson bro you know what
weird man I still remember one time we
drove up I don't even remember I had my
Chrysler 300 you're like looking for a
ride up to a show in the middle of
nowhere and it was like a bar you took
me I took you see that's [__] up you
were probably and uh my velv rope
story was kind of there was like
maybe 60 people at the show it was a bar
but everyone was a red car you had right
no it was a black black car I never had
a nice black shiny car nice rims it's
all coming to me
let y we go way back though like I don't
remember that keep throwing bro we go we
go way back do you remember you used to
[__] bank at the credit union with me
yeah man when I first people bought the
way this we have our guest here um Eddie
Valdez what's up AKA edro AKA [__]
Eddie that's it this guy we I known him
from way back yeah we go way back man
like U way back when this F used to go
to the Laugh Factory and watch the shows
when Benny Mana was hosting Benny Mana
introduc after Joy Medina yeah we used
to go to [__] hang out at Dublin no
this was before Joy Medina before Joy
before Joey we to go to Miyagi right
after the show I've never went with you
to or duins Dublin I've been to a couple
times yeah but uh yeah Benny introduced
me to you uh you were probably one of
the first comedian friends I had I used
to go to the shows a lot I and I got
into comedy late too as far as being a
fan and listening to Comedy and um I
worked out a credit union doing loans
and I had a a a lean on my [__] I had
a lean on my account on my I lean on I
hold on everything I child support for
child support I could get a bank loan
anywhere bro so this fol said I'll hook
it up yeah I like hey bank with me come
cash your checks I'll cash them right
away I won't put holds on your bad ass
dog thank you man because you know when
you deposit your checks right away
they'll put a hold on that [__] and
won't let you uh withdraw so I would I
would release the checks right away and
then he would just take the money
out out of a000 yeah man damn child
support I cat tried to catch my check
well was far going then those food
[__] made me open up a checking
account so I open it up and then like a
week later the $4,000 check the $4,000
check turned into
$3,000 no turn into 1,000 bro who do you
complain to that nobody you can't you
can't they're I mean you owe child
support so
that's don't get nobody pregnant in
California I haven't done that yet
that's the thing too man I've got like
there certain things I'm like you know
what you're doing all right Dusty you
haven't you don't have anyone pregnant
you know so this F screaming out of the
Volvo right out the car now you know
screaming out of the Volo all the way
from Bobby Bowman's house not just
screaming out my whole body was out of
the car like seen in the night I was the
Joker man I was like we have the same
type of body you know very long torso
and short
legs so his legs are dangling but his
whole body is reaching out and grabbing
my head on the other side what the [__]
he has that foot dusy B has that cat dog
body IA yeah it's a yeah he could reach
but he can't kick your ass it's weird
yeah so he yelling bro any Pokemons here
and then on the we're driving and of
course you know um Peter uh
morera he lives not too far away from
Bobby Bowman house cuz they have badass
houses dog so we're going so we see him
walking you know with [__] backpack
[__] 50 48y old rider showrunner of
of Wizard of mbery and they the
wi Wizards of Waverly Plates all I
yelled I just said show runner Show
run we need a
showrunner he texted me after that and
said have a good set man I think that
was a little bit like you know what's up
man been around up me text me to see how
your set went that was more like text me
to see if you're
alive yo so do you still have that
account at the C un I do really hell
yeah they're called Novo now New Vision
New Vision New Vision damn man I'm still
there D and um so this was yelling out
the window all the way to the Improv man
so I make sure I park my car far away
from Cars where do we even Park man I
don't even remember we parked over there
where the where the designer parks
parking lot is oh okay yes nobody has
ever parked there to buy clothes no [__]
the Fred seagull right Fred seagull yeah
Fred seagull by the way is really the
Improv parking if you ever need free
parking if you go to the Improv park
that's at night right when they're
closed anyway so yeah but sometime they
started tripping for a little bit really
yeah the valet dudes they're you got to
give him a little dollar bro give him a
little joint that's what you got to do
you got to go that's a good thing most
of them are Mexican you just talk to
them in Spanish and it's all good I got
to use drugs to get people on my side
that works too so that's I got fipe on
my side hell yeah that food had burn too
I forgot about that f it was edro and
and and it was it was edro because of
dro I thought you last night we had to
bring that Phoenix [__] no that [__] was
horrible man I used to have to get it
from here and take it to Phoenix that's
why edro came about cuz I would bring
the good [__] to Phoenix I was living in
Phoenix for a while but anyways I was at
the credit union for five years and
always going to the comedy clubs Benny
also introduced me to Russell who I work
for Russell Peters and that's how I
started off with him I I worked at this
Credit Union my mom she's unemployed
sells perfumes colog whatever she gets
her hands on she goes to the SWAT meat
and uh perfum
yeah so a friend of hers that works at a
warehouse fake colog like instead of
guci no she was selling good [__] she
was selling fake clothes though like
fake uh bab baby is that how you say it
B when that [__] was popular there were
sixes instead of seven there were L's
instead of seven jeans they were L jeans
so she she uh had a friend who gave her
a box of facial products she's like why
don't you help me sell that [__] I was
like what am I going to do go door to
door what the [__] she's like tell your
friends tell your co-workers is really
good [__]
like you know what let me try eBay
started selling that [__] on eBay we're
were making bank have you ever heard of
this [__] it's called Dermalogica really
expensive high-end [__]
my yeah so we we sold we're selling a
bunch of do those it's facial products
for wrinkle creams uh all kinds of
beauty supplies and uh my mom was
starting to make Bank off of that [__] I
was doing it for her using the post
meter uh for a box that we had each
little cream would be like 80 to 90 on
eBay I would sell it for so in one month
we made like five six G's and just
selling this [__] on eBay so I told my
mom I don't know where you got this [__]
from but if you can get it for a good
price I don't know I mean it was it's
it's a popular product though dude
that's awesome I love like things like
that I used to sell non with my do you
know what like tahan non or something it
was one of those things like it's a
miror made up dude yeah my mom somehow
got into it and like made
I don't know it's like it's like some
it's just juice that's like oh yeah I
think I've heard of it yeah but that's
like a pyramid type of setup no right
this yeah this wasn't yeah so what
happened um we ended up with all this
non
water we were buying this [__] from this
guy who worked at the warehouse right so
he was just selling it out of his trunk
he was probably stealing it from the
warehouse and that's what ended up
happening me and my mom me and my mom
got charged with receiving stolen goods
and we got sentenced to 6 months jail
time with felony oh my god dude the
felony the amount of [__] that my mom
had at her house was valued at over
$50,000 oh man the cops came into the
credit union where he used to come and
cash your checks and they're like you
have to come with us and they didn't
they didn't put me in cuffs but they're
like you have to come with us when do
you start crying dude I like immediately
I'd be like right away I didn't know
what the [__] was going on right I I
cooperated I I told my boss yo I got to
go there's there there's an emergency
right there's an emergency um a death in
the family got
hey I got food poisoning they put us in
jail man and and uh police a a detective
came and started asking us about the
[__] that we were selling on the
internation they're like so what is this
stuff you you're selling on on the
internet I was like some facial products
where where do you get it from I a
friend of ours put us in cuffs we're in
jail and uh you know we we got bailed
out we went through the whole [__]
court process and our lawyers told us
you know what you're going to have to
take take the the whatever the the rap
you're going to have to take you should
um claim that you're you're guilty
because uh there's no way to get out of
it we're buying [__] facial products
out of a guy's trunk you know it's one
of those things where you're buying Avon
or Mary Kay you're supposed to buy from
a licensed
representative and uh who ask for a
license for herb life I know right but
so we got charged credentials we got
charged with receiving stolen goods and
because the amount of [__] that my mom
had in her house it was a felony in 6
months jail time how much tell your mom
do my mom did 2 days thank God I don't
know if the jail was overpopulated or
the computer just kicked her out I did
three months in [__] County jail so
you took the you took the rapper no I D
they they said I was the uh The
Mastermind of the whole operation the
eBay account was in my name the PayPal
account was in my name I was [__]
using the postage meter at work which is
a federal offense oh and you open up a
checking account for a guy I was casing
check for [__] Felipe I was risking
my job way back see and you weren't even
drinking that's I'm like you know well
so because of that my career down the
drain dude that uh it took you to [__]
up in a year took bu to borrow 30
minutes last night
30 oh here's what would be the real
thing if tonight cuz tonight it's so
funny how all this works tonight's a big
industry showcase [__] and I'm on the
show and it's Mar's going to be there
from the the garbage industry yeah I'm
like man felony account felony on my
record I get out January of 09 I did 3
months so I I turned myself in November
of 08 I miss Thanksgiving Christmas New
Year's I get out January 9 econ economy
is at its worse imagine trying to find a
job with a felony on your record and uh
dude it was the lowest point in my life
I was like what the [__] am I going to
do now I my mom tried to take the blame
I was just doing this [__] to help her
all the money was going to her and it
[__] up my career I can't go back into
that industry cuz I had I have a felony
on my record and uh Russell Peters who's
my boss now seven years famous comedian
world famous comedian seven years now in
August I'll be with him and uh yeah the
first weekend I get out I have a text
from him he's saying hey I'm at the BR
improv come hang out if you're even out
of jail I was like shoot I just got out
I go kick it with him first thing right
when I get to the brand improv he's I
see him at his car he's opening his
trunk he's got DVDs um what the [__] do
I do hey you you need help selling those
like f like if I didn't learn my [__]
lesson but no he gave me the box of DVD
like sure you know maybe help me sell
them and that's how it started just he
invited me on the road took a couple
trips with him he paid for everything he
had an assist another assistant at that
time which he hated and uh I kind of
stepped in and started helping him out
little by little and uh yeah I was just
helping him out with a few things and
then he trusted me enough to house it
for him one time and that's when I was
like you know what I'm going to wash all
his cars maybe have my mom come and
clean the house organize his closet and
uh it's when in August is when he asked
me if I wanted to work for him fulltime
so man I got lucky I don't know where
the [__] I'd be
cuz I tried finding a job during that
whole time and it was not possible man
so seven years now in August and uh put
it this way he doesn't even know what
side his gas tank is on so you know I
[__] in charge of the flights
Transportation hotels dry clean
groceries [__] paying the gardener
the pool cleaner the maid whatever needs
take his mom gambling take his mom
gambling to Vegas penny slots all day
man so that's all she cares about face
but dude uh just in two years these last
two years we did 25 countries 150
cities so you could travel now travel
the world even even when I was uh on
probation the first year where the first
week of every month I had to be in LA to
check in with my probation officer no
matter where we [__] traveled we were
always home the first week of the year
just worked out it's crazy and uh I
traveled without ever getting permission
which I was risking it but [__] worked
out breaking the law yeah but now I'm
off I'm off probation of course and uh
got the felony removed from my record so
how' you do that trying to get a a I got
a I even got a felony and I can't get
removed really I was got I was charged
with for having a ounce of crack damn no
ounce two yeah two an ounce and a half
of crack do you have a previous record I
mean I I don't have a that happened 1991
when I was 18 damn and I went to court
no I didn't even go to court it got um
dismissed it got a DA reject okay but
when I go to Canada that [__] shows up
yeah yeah well that's that's your shows
up so I was getting into Canada fine all
the time and just recently last year
they they didn't they kicked me out
they're like you can't get in I was like
why I've been in there they told me I
can't get in you have to fly back home
and that they came to get you at the no
no it was that it was at the airport it
was at the airport and Russell got
pissed actually made the news because he
was on Twitter talking [__] about the
Canada immigration and I was in there
like three times before that year and uh
I guess finally they looked up my record
and they now every time I go in I have
to go into secondary and I had to go to
a lawyer and make sure my felony was
completely dismissed they just had to
give me a paper to get in you know I
flew to Montreal Comedy Festival in 2005
no problem and flew back no problem went
to Amsterdam reram flew back no problem
and um the first time
on the way to um to Canada to work with
Russell when I worked with Russell that
oh yeah the Canada tour you did that
whole Canada tour too right they held me
there for a long ass time and then on on
the way back they held me again when I
flew in in a private jet no problem no
problem
yeah oh so and but when did you get
kicked out then after touring with
Russell or before no I I didn't get I
didn't get I never been kicked out I
just been held I miss my I miss my
that's going to happen every time it's
going to happen every time no matter
what because now you're you're on the
computer so you been 3 hours or 4 hours
earlier than it depends how busy the
airport is but like every time I go now
I got to expect to be held and uh get
questioned even though I I just got to
show my paperwork they got to [__]
check that I haven't been convicted of
anything else I'm feeling so much better
about life after hearing these stories
you know dude man felony's here and
felon don't get Aon don't get a felony
man like
[__] I mean you know what you're a
comedian you can have a felony that's
don't go to
Toronto [__] GoPro for kidnapp oh
they go oh shout out to the real Jo Diaz
not the real Jo Diaz I just said not
Joey Koko Diaz this is the real jodas
listening in Orlando and heard about me
on mediocre time with Tom and Dan the
mediocre podcast was Tom and Dan to do
it out of our backyard awesome podcast
very professional his name just happens
to be Joey Diaz thanks for listening
Joey Kelly
import has been listening to the show
since the beginning she wrote a comment
for us on Soundcloud about going to a
Rodrigo and homie show at the ice house
soon after her mother passed away and
how much better made her feel thanks
Kelly
import Mario too Mario Z Mario Z
listening from San Antonio his
father-in-law introduced him to my
standup special and they're both fans
and give them something to do you know
two guys hanging out Mar also recovering
addict who has started to become more
open about his past since he started
listening to the show and now he's doing
testimonials all over the place DN I
used to be a cholo thanks for listening
Mario and I'll see you in San Antonio
and September I thought it was October
how long have you been sober Filipe
November me yeah I haven't dranked since
2009 damn are you serious years you're
drinking a beer right now no yeah hung
over bro yeah I was really hung over
when I got here well tell you bro this
fo was [__] up by the time I left him
he said all righty I'll get a ride home
I got footage of this fo [__] up oh no
I put on on Snapchat no and see if you
can hear him is and
um the F the funny man this fool gets
more Mexican when I was
there I could see that my Mexican side
coming out it was crazy man if it want
to take over the world do you speak
Spanish Dustin no
PO so this um Dustin iar right here
oh [__] looking like JEA son look
at you bad boy y you have to push it all
the way in the ax cable oh that was bad
this is this is bad oh
God up you [__] [__] [__]
ass that's good intro right there
[__] [__] [__] ass that's a good
intro if you ever have a show
like he start hugging
me that'll be funny huh right
there that's your
Wu start wrestling me man by the stairs
and that's when you uh chok them out
with the Velvet Rope or what hell yeah
bro we don't let the Masashi brother bro
we're like the two Mexican Bushwackers
oh yo I got we ready to [__] somebody up
too hey we went to go we went to go see
a house Russell was thinking of buying
another house and uh the real estate
agent didn't want us to know uh who the
seller was so we're walking around the
house [__] indoor basketball court
selling for $1 million badass house and
uh I walk in the pantry and there's
masaan Guerero tostadas I was like this
guy's got to be Mexican uh walking
around the house there's a bunch of
boxing gloves all over the walls and
there signed by Chavez Barrera Marquez
Canelo he's got to be Mexican and then
and uh we go up to the theater room
there's three post movie posters a day
without a Mexican Muppet baby's movie
Blood and blood out and um and Beverly
Hills Chihuahua which had a lot of
Mexican actors in it so I was like who
the [__] is this guy and the the the
real estate agent like you're not going
to find out if you do if you do I'll
give you $1,000 I like man the internet
is a powerful thing man I started
looking on there and there was a two
banners in the basketball court that
said Danielle and Edward I was like one
of them's got to be Danielle or Edward
or maybe that's a son's names anyway I
ended up finding out you know whose
house that was biolene and La Manana oh
[__] really $1 million house I was like
then I started looking into him I was
like uh when he was the hottest show in
in La he was making 5 mil a year you
still can't afford that house he made
his money he made his money in real
estate he bought a house sold it for a
shitload of money and it sucks with
everything that happened to him year
what happened to him he got sexual
harassment he got he got sued for sexual
harassment he said he was groping his uh
cooworker
in front of them what was this a dude
right yeah but it was it was it was more
like it was more like grab ass and
making a guy feel uncomfortable you know
like you know how pis do it
hey [__] he had to leave the he got
he had to leave the show and I think
that's why he had to sell the house yeah
and he ended up going to um a smaller
station I can't believe that I think
he's doing serious yeah really yeah he's
on serious that's right he on serious
and he was working on a pilot with Paul
Rodriguez and his neighbors with Mar
Antonio Solis and Britney
Spears that's a lot of money for a disc
CH like Howard Stern money yeah man I
was surprised well he did beat on Howard
Stern when he was here really in La damn
is this is a Spanish station or is it
like it's is the guy Spanish he's he's
he's like the big boy of Mexican right
now I know I've seen his uh posters like
I guess they're not up anymore though
but yeah when I I would see he some nice
veneers let me tell you yeah and that's
right and then I we always see him at
the at the boxing fights you know
Russell's a big boxing fan and I was
like damn this guy you make good friends
with
him is real cool man also there another
guy that makes a lot of money and radio
I don't know if he thre around Ki KI
yeah Ki was uh he's the OG of it right
he started that long time
ago he got out he got let go too because
he got too political
really oh yeah man that's what's going
to happen so what's up
fool of upcoming shows man I'll be in
Corpus Christie Texas July 21st to the
23rd at mosquet Street Comedy Club New
York City July 28th to the 31st at
Carolines on Broadway tell all your
friends I'm coming to New York Bates
yeah West West Palm Beach Florida August
4th through the 7th at The Improv and we
have a few free tickets to give away for
these shows so email me at fans
felipesworld decom for West Palm Beach
only and say what's up fool give me some
tickets Hermosa Beach California August
10 one night only at the comedy magic
club one night good club good Club
Tucson Arizona August 12th Pueblo
California August 13 one night only at
the ICC at the TCC Music Hall in Tucson
Arizona also one night only at Pueblo
Memorial Mall or Hall don't worry people
I know you guys have a p Califor preo
Colorado there's been a lot of Latino
shows that been over there that been
cancelled but Felipe were not cancelled
cuz this show is going to sold sell out
to all your friends to be there what you
got going on Dustin iar um I'm at comedy
magic club August 19th and uh yeah I'll
be over there then um H's comedy club in
um like September look at all up at
doesn't a bar.com unless they're all
taken away by then I might have ruined
everything by then also shout out to uh
our past guest rafhael Cardenas he has a
book that came out right now it's called
the
um
masaka photographed by Rafael Cardenas
you guys remember him he was on our show
see that and he talked about um every
day he took a photo in BO Heights and
heay every day for 365 days wow and so
all of the photo that he picked out of
the 365 days are in his book that's $200
but it's a good coffee book and he'll
sign it it's a [__] badass book if
you're into Bo Heights East and the east
side also there's a photo of me of me in
there that he took what page what page
uh it's under the Sixth Street Bridge
better memorize that page number it's um
it's in there and they're all in black
and white and it's a good collection of
photos also a cheaper book is will be
out later on in the future but this book
right here only a limited edition of
coming only aund of them so get them now
and he it's a hard book cover nobody
makes hard book no more no only hardcore
baby yeah get it at Rafa
Rafa
La also man I supposed to give a shout
out to somebody um when I was in San
Diego also July 15 there's no hum freeze
by the bay show no show in San Diego
that show has been moved to October 2
21th first and shout out to my homie out
there at the record
store fet record in San Diego fet
records this guy always promotes my show
and he always hooks me up with comedy
albums and he hooked me up with his
Gallagher album nice it's a a comedy
album of Gallagher and if you open the
inside there's um throw up pieces of
bananas and a baby
Hammer have you done humph in San Diego
yes for Last Comic Standing though oh
that's just that that venue is dope it's
badass yeah you know what I got you know
when you at J improv you always meet
people you know if you're into like the
party scene like Dustin iara you know
people got to meet Dustin iara and
Philip SPS last night we saw Eliza
schlinger I reached out to shake her
hand she reached out for the hug I said
okay let's hug it up we saw Margaret
show not oh [__] I forgot about that
that's right killing it she's been in it
for a while
yeah Margaret show is there and um Chris
Newberg did we run into Chris Newberg
there he said what's up man he was
sweating for that 20 minutes oh he yeah
he always sweats Russell's taking him on
the road uh and to to Asia with us and
he went to the Middle East with us oh
that's cool I like I love J man oh yeah
and Felipe you know it's funny cuz when
uh for that Canada tour and I remember
one of the first big shows that he did
for Russell was in Vegas Vegas bro and
Russell was looking for someone to open
up up and I mentioned you and he's like
he's a he's a headliner he doesn't want
to open up for me he's like hell yeah he
would and uh that's how it started and
Russell Russell loved you when you did
Vegas and that's why he uh had you do
the Canada tour too I loved it too man I
was surprised by the money I was like
had to chase him down he he'll pay he's
one of the higher paying Comics as far
as paying his openers damn who's opening
for him right now get in there get in
line buddy get in line I dude I know
right I know maybe if you showed up to
the house for the movie I had like Ed
edro can't even walk into a room without
people to put in her giving them her 8
by
10 their resume hey man how's Russell by
the way dude I bet I bet you they were
talking was Jo all like he was bummed
out but they made it work whatever it
goes on big big Shut over there at a big
meeting yo but that was right before uh
Last Comic Standing too that Vegas show
right that was like the beginning of the
end for Philipe fol let me
tell bad ass show bro one show at the
Hilton I got to meet [__] George
Wallace a George wall is awesome man at
the Hard Rock I got to meet George W oh
yeah he was at that show that's right he
came I got to meet um um Russell Peter
personal trainer in
Vegas really had a train black oh yeah
damn I forgot about that what the [__]
Hank I don't know his name
man she get in shape Larry hit up one of
those funny names get in shape Larry
let's go champ I don't know who's let's
go champ I don't know his name a dude I
don't even remember that so this fool
man started wrestling with me man by the
bathroom I like how we go back there a
show going on yeah no people get were
sitting down barely and then started
sitting me down so then I said [__] it
the Laugh Factory yeah they got the
valet rope bro and started spanking over
there bro crawling up the stairs like a
baby crying I think I remember okay okay
now remember why I had a bloody that
triggered his memory must have fell down
that triggered his memory see that time
crawling up the stairs fell down he got
like carpet burners or
something they disappeared and hung up
by the by the like the by the bar for a
long ass time damn dude there are people
let I've got now right now I'm going
through that anxiety of like you know
how like you're like oh who else did I
run into who else could have did I [__]
up and what cuz there's a buddy of mine
was there Daniel wine
no Daniel weard and I remember seeing
him but I'm like I remember he was kind
of being a dick and whenever you're
drunk and someone's being a dick you
kind of are like I was probably being a
dick you know who's that damn Daniel
he's a buddy of mine a comic uh he goes
haha a lot he's really fine was the last
time been in the haha [__] since the
last time I was there bro I Tred to
choke the devil at the haha you tried to
what choke the devil choke the devil huh
2007 man what the [__]
D oh [__] oh Jeff
Garcia that's I think I heard of that
story I threw water in his face he threw
water in my face so I figured that's
going to lead to a fight what so then I
started Chas then that fool ran like a
[__] dog yeah r Wait so are you guys
cool now or no hell no he ran bro I
never I never seen a guy run from a
fight but he ran and they started
taunting me like a little kid like hey
like trying to hide and [__] like
this hiding dog he hiding behind a
female he was hiding behind a
female bad boy so he was supposed to be
lente bad boy bro I'm from La pente so
it kind of feel kind of embarrasses me a
little that he ran away from me he's a
little girl bro that's funny man a
little [__] how do you see how do you
he ran from a fight and if you're to
[__] jump with jump with a [__]
get to the if you need to Dance with the
Devil bro you better get ready to lead
or follow bro so so why did you threw
water his face first yeah and why oh cuz
you know like he kept like you know he
kept talking and talking and like he
didn't let me talk he didn't let my wife
talk so nobody could get a word in Then
I then I finally got a my word in and I
said fighting words bro I got in his
face and I said listen man I don't give
a [__] if you made
$400,000 yeah you made that [__] with
cartoons bro yeah you're you're not a
real comedian I'm a real comedian bro
I'm funnier in you and that's why your
wife wants to suck my dick oh
[__] dude FIP and you still threw water
at him first water him bro I hear a
story like that and I'm like like me bro
I'm the kind of guy when you [__] with
me I'm going to make it uncomfortable
you to walk into the city bro Dustin the
[__] you've done is
nothing if that happened to me I would
wake up every day for the rest of my
life thinking what have I done oh man
has burn some bridges bro God damn you
have man that's even a bridge bro that's
a [__] r
downhill
too that's a [__] boost bro to get a
book damn dude yeah that's crazy
man I don't burn Bridges bro I burn
ramps I [__] need I need you to
[__] I burn you on the way
up I should be a bumper sticker bro I
don't burn bridg I burn Rams bro
so then F that's like the first time I
ran into that [__] right yeah so
I when I won last Comic that like no
this fool like afterwards like since
like you can't beat up Filipe physically
you know so you got to go another [__]
way right so this fo um Jeff Garcia was
headlining the ice house right and um
Lisa was a waitress there so he went to
go talk to the manager and say he man I
feel very very UNC comfortable if this
girl works here damn without even saying
it's because I don't like Felipe spa so
I'm be a little [__] so that's been
that's the worst man that's the worst I
can't stand that when when it happens in
comedy it when Comics go out of their
way to [__] you know to say don't let
this comic Joe Cy did that too bro the
Laugh Factory Joe Koy see he's hard he's
hard to find bro oh man he's hard to
grab wherever he's at like he's Pokemon
he
has like
a Joe is like a Pokemon bro you're
trying to cash with no
WiFi so I couldn't I couldn't hold him
the devil Jeff Garcia I could hold him
did you try to fight jooy I didn't know
you guys you you and like each other n
[__] that
fool he pulled a same [__] bro but
without even knowing that I didn't like
him he didn't like me all of a sudden
Lisa can't work at the Laugh Factory
because Jeff because um Joe Koy is there
but [__] Joe Koy bro he's out of my he's
out of my league he's out of you know
that's another ramp I had to
burn so getting back to this
[__] right feel I'm at the I'm
at the I'm at the sunset room day and
night bro Monday nights getting [__]
up there you know I talked to about inch
castle and um this fool shows up on the
night I won Last Comic Standing nice at
the sunset room I was sober by oh I
heard this story I was sober right so
this F this fo figures you know he
showed up at the sunset room because I
was going to be there so he figured you
know maybe Felipe after winning
$250,000 but want to pick up an assault
charge
too that was his plan that was Jeff G
Jeff Garcia's plan that was the devil
that was his plan bro if if anybody out
there that's why he's called the devil
because the devil doesn't doesn't do
[__] to you he plans [__] out for you
for you to [__] up and make bad
decisions so that's what the devil is
the devil so the devil shows up
to the devil shows up to Georgia he were
looking for a soda steel he shows up to
um the sunset room bro the bad boy dog
he's on stage you know doing his his
same [__] comedy same [__] I've
heard since what that's one of the first
I remember listening to and even now
when I see him saying the first time you
see him he fools you bro like a [__]
like like a Ponzi scheme you know yeah
he fools you with millions of dollars of
Comedy right but then you kept going
back you keep getting $10 here $20 here
but but his comedy is like um he asked
us a cholo hey [__] cholo [__]
[__] a [__] stab somebody then
they go hey black guy you win all the
gold medals hey white guy you [__] Su
whatever hey Chinese guy you [__]
can't drive very generic [__] up my
insurance so then at the end of the show
he goes back to everybody so he'll do a
10-minute bid about cholos a 10-minute
bid about blacks a 10-minute bid about
white people can't dance a 10-minute bit
about Chinese people can't drive [__]
raising my car insurance that's I I'm
driving Al Hamra you know what I mean I
know the bits it's a setup bro it's like
a game it's like a improv game what he
does on stage it's as bad as bringing
out your [__] hands behind someone's
back like Eric Blake yeah yeah that's so
funny I back in the day man back when I
first started comedy I saw him in Corpus
and I remembering it that [__] was funny
too but someone told me that cuz I yeah
I was like oh this is hilarious and then
someone's like yeah but but that [__]
that did yeah the [__] that Garcia does
in peace the [__] that he does makes it
look like he's dope with improv but it's
the same to the new audience yeah to the
new audience but when you ask that food
to write down a 5 minute s tonight's
show you know is the audience going to
be
miked so getting back to this fool right
so this fo knows that I want Last Comic
Standing you know because his wife was
probably voting for
me the only reason I said that to him
bro honestly the only reason I said that
to him because I knew that his wife
cheated on him was a fireman ah and I
remember one time I showed up with an ny
PD fire shirt at one of his shows oh
[__] that's hilarious I was trying to
find a fireman hat but I couldn't
imagine bro your wife [__] a fireman
and Filipe knows and he shows up with a
water hose and a fireman hat so [__]
fire hose wrapped around your [__]
neck like AAR be for a while bro what's
up with like so yeah he was being
introduced one time I it all LED you
know he was being introduced one time
you guys ready for the greatest comedian
ever and I stand up [__] loaded like
you were last night and I yell who's
here [__] Gabriel Elias [__] that
[__] oh so there two people at the same
time Gabriel and his show tell me more
your [__] up story so I got hear this
so I'm there at the sunset he's at the
sunset room doing that's next level you
got to start talking [__] to other
community oh I haven't done that yet I
hear that that's where it's
leading yeah man you're in room level
talking [__] to about people without
saying their names yeah
yeah you got go and guess look it up on
the
internet so I'm at the sunset room and I
just one last comment standing I [__]
just left a big ass party for all the
for the winners Craig Robinson was there
the late Greg Geraldo was there we had a
one onone he turned down a lot of drugs
that night too by the way I saw him turn
down drugs wow I got to meet him in New
York and um so after that [__] I saw
[__] Roy Wood Jr [__] up bro like
[__] up like really [__] he
was [__] loaded yeah man he was his
tweet was um yeah man just joink wear
the third place blues oh man or fourth
place
Blues all mad dog cuz Lisa was looking
like a fox a that is so funny she red
dress looking like a fox and he go this
your priz too [__] yeah mother
[__] I'm going be a citizen too and um
so after that bro they had this big old
party also in East Los Angeles at some
ghetto ass bar bro where they used to
pull guns out on people the Mongol used
to hang out right there and the [__]
um mava gang no the Gold Room it used to
be called the East Rudy baring Grill on
Pomona I go to East Side love have you
ever been there yeah in BO height so I'm
there bro a bunch of cholos I'm wearing
my suit yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever
then after that I went to another party
three parties
bro last time he wore a suit too by the
way yeah the room dog you were during
this time yeah man so when I get would
you even go out you just won last Comic
man so over there man so I see Jeff
Garcia bro the devil perform me I walked
up to him and I [__] snatched the
microphone like a boss dude I if you
want to see how I snatched his phone you
want to see how I snatched the
microphone off his [__] woman
hands his hands feel like somebody that
never hit nobody somebody never G up
nobody but a microphone people who never
held a shovel never held a box never
held a lawn mower and I know that
because Richard V used to mow his lawn
oh [__] what the [__] yeah bro I don't I
don't hold back Whata F podcast get on
the ratings damn dude so we're trying to
get to 100 godamn
it be yeah man anyways it's getting hot
in here
I snatched the microphone away from him
and I said get the [__] out of my
face showed up [__] Last Comic
Standing winner yes this is all in his
face my breath he can feel my sweat
there's
anger I'm going be violated I'm G pick
up a strike I can't go to Canada anyway
so get the [__] out of my face D so real
ComEd showed up I don't ask questions I
have a [__] set what kind of question
did he ask hey hey hey where you
from real ComEd [__] that's
$250,000 I made in one night yeah in one
night and then that fool that there
shaking dog I swear to God if you get
out my face I'm going [__] beat the
[__] out of you in front of
everybody can you imagine this he has a
suit on too
man an audience M would be the oddest
[__] ever like what the [__] is that
[__] shine
box so it's getting heated dog
everybody's there bro George Perez is
there yeah George Perez is there shago
is there um Rizzle is there Johnny Rock
everybody's there bro all the when I was
there after I Punk that food like a
[__] bro man that fool was could he was
outside you know trying to let a
cigarette and sh told me that his wife
said that yeah man he was having a hard
time ligh his
cigarette he was
shaking you know I know and she said she
stood up said I know this guy's an
[__] but I felt bad for
him dude that's so funny so there we got
pked right so then I'm thinking then I'm
thinking I'm glad somebody help me back
think about it bro this [__]
comedian Filipe SPS just won
$250,000 right been all over the news ju
the [__] Last Comic Standing donated
money to Goodwill whatever homeboy
industry and choked a comedian to death
do you think that was like your version
of like you're like I've got this now I
got to [__] it up how
do [__] I felt you know what it
felt like after one last comment
standing it changed me bro I turned into
Bill Murray when in Kingpin at the
end so how do you feel so how do you
feel Mr mcracken how do you feel about
winning last coming about winning the
bowling chair I feel I feel above the
law was there any pressure was there any
pressure [__] you have a pressure I
didn't want to lose to a guy with a
hook Rob's M that's the best [__] lie
dog talk about a s loser his hair all
[__] up DG he [__] looks at a hot
streek I'm a room to s
yeah that might have been a funny dude
that's a funny ass build that's how I
[__] felt when I W com I still have
that the picture of your face like I
screenshoted that [__] when you
won oh Eddie was there yeah I was there
my son thought you were my
son yeah cuz when he won on the TV it
said Felipe's family it was me Lisa and
his and felipa's
daughter I just got invited I was like
[__] high five you
yeah it dud when you were there dog you
it was sad for Tommy
johnan cuz um that fool thought he was
going to win too right you know
everybody thought something you know I
never thought it was going to win I
thought it was going to move on to
success either way win or lose I would
have won but it was glad I won yeah yeah
so that food we're standing there
together right Last Comic Standing we're
standing together and then the whole
everybody they calling all the Vates
they ain't no votes they're gonna
announce the winner now you're hear in
the audience
Felipe
fipe fipe fipe Felipe Tommy all quiet
and [__] like yeah I was going to say
actually said can we get a
Tommy yeah that's so funny Asian woman
from the FR your love
Tommy he said thank
you fo you know what it felt like now
Jeet Bush being up there bro oh oh damn
yeah please say thanks yeah please clap
Tommy joh I love Tommy joh he's awesome
man please clap I forgot that you got it
was it was YouTube right yeah man when
we were on tour F that F was trying to
go over dog like everybody's about do 20
minutes so he try to pull that rookie
[__] dog you know like dude like one
night he did 37 minutes damn and then I
to 20 he did 37 in La which is your Dam
he did 37 in La was in my hotel bro yeah
bro and and it was and like if you're
going to do 37 minutes make sure you get
a standing ovation after so it wasn't
even a standing ovation bro and then if
you go if you look it up man look up
last comment standing review of
Charlotte North Carolina there's a guy
who wrote A a bit a review about that
show and he writes that he went over and
to do 37 minutes but Filipe SP K me like
a champ and got off in 15 with a rocking
sense you know matter you cannot if you
ever lose to somebody and you're going
to tour with them you know don't show a
sad face because no matter what you know
you're going to always look like a loser
you know phip is going to have a raving
podcast where he's going to
mention this dude Tommy would also wait
make us wait 35 minutes for him inside
the bus what the [__] like I might have
won the show but he was the diva Tomy
Tommy does have his [__] together though
he like yeah he's like working on [__]
and then like
I didn't know that I
guess and then like I was like I was
everybody's get complaining you know
complaining it's taking forever you know
calling whatever fool I'm outside
finishing that blunt yeah I'm going to
back of the bus smoking a blood by
myself like a soldier in Flint Michigan
that's hilarious so he was that that
would happened so I'm at the I'm at the
sunset room bro and this food I snatched
the microphone away from him he [__]
walks away like a little [__] he ends
up driving home bro did you have to do
the set after that hell yeah bro it was
part it was hard to bring the crowd back
I I was going to say like so what are
you guys up
to yeah man um so kind of I kind of like
um when I was yelling at him goes [__]
this [__] right here this guy's a
[__] [__] this guy doesn't like me
you know this guy try to get my chick
fired from the Ice House you know didn't
let her workot a lot of women single
yeah yeah [__] this
guy then the manager walked up to him
bro and said man you're going to have to
leave they made him leave bro no
way yeah I'm probably going to get in
trouble just for being on your podcast
man people were talking whenever I tell
your name it's so funny man uh who did I
run into the other day was like Alfred
roess yeah that's Alfred was like so you
have fun of Felipe's podcast I've known
Al forever he's gri Gia lobbyist yeah
hey now I have a story about Gabriel you
know uh Russell and Gabriel did some
shows together big ass show right with
bur with Steve Burn Lampanelli I mean it
was great damn and Steve Lanell Steve
bur Steve
lell I should get [__] up they say
name right and I'm missing someone else
somebody big yeah [__] I can't remember
right no Jeff Dam no so anyway everyone
had their set time as well and Russell
decided he's going to host it obviously
the two big names on that thing were
Russell on Gabriel yeah and um Russell
decided to host it and uh Gabriel would
be the last one up and would go over his
time and make all of us wait and do
instead of 30 minutes there was even one
show he did for an hour after an hour
show already and uh yeah we won't work
with him again but I mean I love Gabriel
but that's interesting I never
understood that Concept in comedy and
maybe it's just my personality typ I
just don't want to be going dude I if I
would understand if it was like oh I I
I'm I'm [__] killing and I got I I'm
going to get a standing oh and this is
going to be awesome but whenever it's
like yeah it was already to the point
you know where you could feel the crowds
kind of getting tired already it's at
two hours of show and Gabriel's like who
wants to hear my old [__] and I never
understood that you know he does aipe
all right back at I was like I'm from
Dallas and at the Addison Improv there
was cats who would come in it's just
like oh so and so's doing like three
hours you mean hyenas right you mean
hyenas that's funny um yeah you're right
damn Fu improv hook me up man I'm your
home boy you're not even booking me yo
but so it was five shows that we did
with him Jeff BR it's Jeff after two
shows after two shows we told we uh we
went to Gabriel's uh people and like yo
what's up with him going over man like
and he still didn't he still went over
after we talked to his managers and
we're like you know can you tell them
not go over we got Lampanelli and
Russell and burn he's got a reputation
he always goes over though right but if
it's your show that's fine do whatever
you want but but something like this
yeah whenever it's like other com this
was called the the something majority
tour and it was Russell and Gabriel's
thing so interesting but there was
another comic though there was another
comic I can't remember right now damn
roywood junor man I got him in trouble
one time I think roywood Junior whenever
I first started whenever I moved to New
York I got my agent and he hooked me up
with a college gig to open for Roy and
he was like man you got to tell these
agents like what to do man you got to
get on their at like he he gave me I'm
like oh yeah yeah yeah and I I call my
remember I called my agent and I was
like hey man um I was talking to Roo J
and he told me I need to be doing this
he's like dude don't [__] listen to
him don't are you [__] serious like
he was like one of those like he hated
it's so funny because it's someone he's
not even with now I'm pretty sure he's
not with him but it's like oh man those
those guys write comedy man Tommy
johnigan and Roy W Jr cuz we were going
to places where those food never venture
to Bro on the last Comic tiing tour like
those places where we went to where I
was surprised I had fans like
Pennsylvania we were in um allent town
and in the front row bro I looked down
when I went up on stage and I saw it was
a [__] four me um old [__]
bro white [__] and two of them
had [__] vote for Felipe shorts on
they made nice and I said yeah
[__] you could go over bro but I
want the
crowd so yeah man so what happened bro
what time you finally make it home
finally made it oh and here's man my
girlfri broke up with me tell me you ate
something to [__] up your body more I
ate nothing I ate no food Lisa no food
bro Lisa Edie you know what this
[__] I tell you what all he ate
a big [__] bite of my jack fruit
burrito that's right that was so good
bro I remember thinking like oh
sustenance h this is so dude I did have
a big ass leg I didn't even know if I
asked you for I didn't even know here
have a bite I didn't give a [__] right
but your food took a bite like you you
you took one of those bites you let your
little brother bite like like this like
like one of those bites you know what
I'm never going to give my little
brother a bite of my burrito no I
deepthroated that burrito it was a big
bite yeah so what end up happening that
night with your you didn't eat no so I
went back and by my girlfriend was
pissing me all day cuz I went
you know how like I'm still in that mode
like you don't know or a long a long day
like well the girlfriend is a new thing
to Comedy so I'm not sure like when I
should how long have you been with her
huh how long have you been with her like
two years together yeah but I'm very
like I'm like okay should we go out am I
going to be that guy with a girlfriend
now all the time that goes out and a lot
of [__] just gets in my head you know
you think about these things cuz you're
like oh are they Wan as should are they
wanting just to be a dude's thing and
I'm going to be the guy showing up with
a girlfriend I but then you start
thinking about man [__] am I going to be
the together please the [__] Chi to
the comedy to The Comedy Store to improv
then we break up then I see this [__]
somebody else dude I've had a oh bro I
got a crazy ex is trying to get in this
business so bad man I hate that [__] oh
it's insane I know one time I was
[__] we're talking about this you
know with my wife then my wife um I
don't knowwhere bro bust a notepad and
goes yeah flipp I've been working on
this 10 minute set right now D I [__]
died dog I [__] died had a [__]
heart
attack my ex started no she put [__]
not never seen before Oh [__] and
stickers
funny sticker Lucy K jerking
off my ex started a podcast here shut up
a relationship coach which is so weird
it's called it's called Dustin the win
dude she [__] talks so much [__]
that's
hilarious D um you know bro you know
what's funny about last night I
told she was trying to get all my best
friends to do the podcast no one did
except except for Nick and I last night
I saw him and I was like dude man you
know you really like that why' you do
that and he was like oh he didn't ask
you first or anything no cuz I we we're
like it's it's a weird thing like we're
like f we we started out together we
like best friends but like fall out yeah
we liveed togethera yeah yeah um so
anyway he was like I was like dude why
did you do that man you knew that it
would you your exgirlfriend wanted to
show your ex-girlfriend wanted to come
to a show and I was like no that'd be
kind of weird CU it'd be you know you
and Nick and so I was like why'd you do
that and he was like I don't know man he
was really heartfelt and apologized I
was like man that's pretty nice but
didn't talk [__] about you on it did he
he did they did really they talked bad
yeah they didn't mention my name but it
was like obvious that you guys are
talking about me and I couldn't I was
like I was like bro that [__] hurt
man you're like you're my best friend I
I would never think to do that so you
guys obviously were're not on good terms
at that time no but now it's been cool
lately at that time you yeah at that
time yeah at that time um yeah but we're
I guess we're cool now it's weird though
cuz you know that it's not the same it's
not the same and I hate it and I'm like
I'm one of those guys I just want
everyone to get along I want to have
friends and I'm like but there is some
it's like ah what are we you know are we
just like yeah [__] Dust in the Wind
pod podcast over there I know bro she's
going to ask you next be on it next week
oh yeah [__] getting [__] up all the
time I hate when that [__] happen bro it
happen bro like fool I was dating some
chick bro at one time she was a waitress
at the [__] um Mont Balo at gothams
and like and and then um she had a twin
sister but I never knew which twin
whatever right but one time we ended up
dating she end be my girlfriend but it
was kind of [__] up you know because
she was a twin
and um they asked me um I asked you know
like a typical dude you know response
right philppe I think the twin one likes
you and he goes which one the one with a
fatter
ass so by the way she's a fatter ass
twin fatter ass the fatter ass F ass so
later on me I stopped dating this chick
right I broke her heart ended up
cheating on her you know the usual you
know the usual it was sad you know smack
the microphone out of her hand was a
[__] up one you know it was one of
those I got caught cheating because um
for those it was old school man it was
before cell phones it was before being a
being a this is a [__] rookie mistake
um I was checking my voicemail from her
house so I check the voicemail right I
was checking there's a bunch of
different chicks food calling in
checking their aals for the weekend you
knows what you want fat ass I might be
able to get you a 900 p.m. spot yeah man
yeah they will call you in their veils
and call him me up call him back yeah
man we we could um we have a we have a
open set for 10:00 tonight you know a
little Felipe um VH and
chill any I didn't hang up the phone
right I didn't hang up the phone right
right her [__] twin sister was on the
other line picked up the phone I guess
immediately after I hung up no and she
[__] of course she started listening
dog damn and she went through all
everything and then she goes oh my God
sis oh oh my God
sis so F they must have [__] went
through everything fast dog they was to
listen through that from her house to
the gas station was like a 5 minute
drive less than that cuz by the time I
went over there bro I went to the gas
station and I put in gas and I come out
the bathroom you know you know watching
my face you know getting ready for my
next date
probably whatever I was doing I was
taking a big ass [__]
at the gas station I was trying to leave
house get ready her house was perfect
bro I would leave her house go to the
gas station finally take a take a
[__] good ass [__] that I want to
take out her house so when she came out
of the house when she when I come out of
the bathroom she goes what the she
didn't say what the [__] she just said
whatever you know you cheat on me I hate
she was already
heartbroken she [__] y me to the gas
station I said I said I'm sorry all
right whatever you [__] just leave me
here whatever right so I in a car and
take off we broke up that it's sad you
know how I got I got busted because I
put there's this it's the same [__] X
that's probably why she hates me um I
had this the Dust in the Wind podcast
Dust in the Wind podcast I saved this
girl that I met in Austin I I put her
name as my brother's name Jared and I
got a text message from Jared here's
what got me too cuz you know how on the
iPhone there's a dot dot dot and she
knew my brother didn't have an iPhone
she was like did you get an iPhone and
I'm like uh what the [__] I just
straight up was like you got me and I'm
sorry and you got me uh Jared from a
Subway huh yeah you can say it was
another Jared I I should have been why
does Jared want to lick your nuts okay I
don't my brother's very uh we have a
close family so fool this chick right I
never thought this chick would try to
get me back right you know you never
think that from a jake right so yeah
dude I learned that they [__] bro so
just just like you bro right so this
[__] right I can see like comedy right
this [__] started talking with Ed wion
Juan oh [__] but behind my back I didn't
know right so Ed wison one told me and I
said well [__] at least he told me right
but I don't know what's going on right
so [__] dude um Ernie G this [__]
hack comedian bro Ernie is [__] over
there being a perb turn to to my back
and talking [__] about me too well I
heard if I was you if um so you're
getting back with him right so really
cuz I just finished seeing him with this
other chick recently what so so when
this chick didn't want to tell me who
told all the information I felt that you
know I can't trust her you know even
though I cheated her a bunch of
times as soon as it comes back I it's
not right right you're not right that's
how I that's how I was in my maturity of
a man yeah yeah right yeah so I'm I'm
more pissed now instead of being still
like sad that this Chi cried through the
whole movie you know
every because of me H trying to make
things work Miss three days of work
never said I was sorry I'm mad because
she's holy back and telling me who told
her that that's funny D Ernie G Ernie G
so whatever so yeah whatever man you
know what sucks I'm pretty sure that
that last girl the psycho one like yeah
I was a bad boyfriend with her just cuz
iy you the bad boy look bro you're like
but now but my girlf dude my girlfriend
now though were like I'm such a good
boyfriend I'm almost too good like I
like [__] I do everything I'm almost too
good just I'm like good bro it's like
I'm doing things that I'm supposed to be
doing but now I want I want
acknowledgement yeah right dude I'm like
props and I I tell her sometimes like
you have no idea you oh man what man I
used to be bad you I think is you never
knew you were so thoughtful right well
I'm just like after that one I was like
you know what I should probably be a
good
guy and I she deserves it I know but
then I'm like a you don't even know how
bad I was Lady happened to what happened
when you came in last night you came in
[__] screaming I was just leave yeah
so I I came in and she said I don't
remember last night she said that I she
said that I I was just walking into
things and she said that she saw my Uber
and jumped in bed she didn't she was so
pissed she was like I don't even know
[__] saw yeah she saw us coming was like
I'm jumping the bed um so this morning
though oh my God bro oh I got it so bad
I got it so [__] bad just like and
and I was hung over and I was getting
yelled at and like I was just I put the
T-shirt over my head and I was like I'm
sorry babe I'm sorry just cuz he came
home drunk and cuz I well I was supposed
to textt her after Bing leavs it was
like one of those situations I like are
girls like is everyone bring our
girlfriends and like it turns out it was
like a bunch of people showed up so I
was like but when I told her before I
was like babe just come and she's like
no I don't want to and I'm like so I
figured she'd be cool but no yeah yeah
so she was really pissed at me and I
don't know luckily I turned on the dusty
charm this morning
and Dusty turned on the dusty Dustin AAR
charm and uh I think I got her that's
what reeled her in the first time right
I love it too man I [__] love I love
whenever you're in trouble and then
you're like it's working like like she's
not mad at me as much anymore a l of
female listener bro what is the dusty
charm bro take a shower or what it's
like
a Bott you left behind he curls his hair
a bit just I'll have a moment of
dramatic like uh
like babe I what if I become bro did you
did have you thrown in the and didn't
have a dad l
every night dude I the thing is I was
raise Jehovah's Witness too so I didn't
have birthdays or Christmases so I'm
like come on baby I didn't know
Christmas you have Good Feet you must
have Good Feet what said you must have
good feet and knocking hands bro knock
somebody out dog that's so that's why
you needed me there last night bro you
needed a witness I did yo that's a good
one now since you were Jehovah's Witness
you've never celebrated a birthday or
nothing I know the first thing I've ever
celebrated is our anniversary oh I got
to use that it's going in the pamphlet
it's going in the
notebook that man that's the perfect guy
right there man Jehovah Witness an a
dude you g your [__] for Valentine's Day
every time you give somebody but wait
can't you guys have like five
wives you're like mixing up like seven I
like how every other religion it's not
the main one gets pushed in all right
you got that little like you guys are
[__] weird you probably having are
you still Jo's witness um I go to church
sometimes Mormon yeah Mormon I go to
church sometimes if I'm feeling really
bad you celebrate your birthday no I've
never celebrated my birthday do you tell
anyone when your birthday is every day
is a party bro n i every day is a party
you know how old you are dude you know
what's funny I thought today what is
today Tuesday what's the day dat
Wednesday July 13th okay my birthday is
July 19th I was like is my birthday
today like I couldn't CU I just don't
pay attention and [__] that' be cool man
you you can get away with a lot of [__]
man like if you buy something nice for
somebody on Valentine's Day you know I
don't [__] really celebrate
Valentine's Day Ever but I'm you
something yes and that's what sucks too
in these relationships cuz I'm like man
I've never had it been obligated to buy
someone a gift it feels weird like oh
now I have to buy you a gift it's not
coming from my heart it's just cuz this
is the calendar so I got to [__] buy
you a
gift I don't know that's when it's
awesome to have that religion you're
like sorry [__] [__] fool oh dude
getting back to the [__] um your
chick starting a podcast and our chick
starting to do standup comedy one time
we were all hanging out and um and then
my chick said maybe I should be a
comedian and then I said why you're not
even [__]
funny that is what planted the scene
it's going to make her Christmas that's
a Filipa charm not Lisa she's funny you
know some other chick the same chick
right and then I said but why you're not
even [__] funny then she got a hurt
right and then I told all my friends
about that [__] and they all
died I was so then bro I was I was
talking about something and you want to
hear something funny and then this St
stupid idiot said right in front of my
chick I know Le I know most of them
didn't say
it oh my god oh the the girl the girl
the twin he said her name I know she
didn't say it cuz I know she ain't
funny they laugh even shoot her down
even more right there
idiot but she was funny than that
[__] though that's funny man
dude that [__] sucked at comedy
bro I want to say his name bro he
brought a chick to the show not Ernie G
no he bombed so hard the chick told him
in front of everybody maybe it's not for
you damn dude that's a worst you ever
see an unfunny comic you apologize for
for them I saw something last night bro
The Improv bro when an unfunny comic
brings a girl out and it's like bro why
would you she better be you're showing
her your worst quality you know do that
it's a good one bro you're right about
that it's so true man it's like why
would you do that you're you're showing
her you're unfunny and sure you're on
stage but she's going to watch you bomb
she you think she wants to [__] you
after that I know man she start feeling
sorry for you maybe a syy that's when
it's bad when you start when you start
apologizing for your friend up on stage
like damn sorry I don't know what's
going on he usually doesn't bomb this
bad especially if you invite 20
employees from your job oh you [__]
Su that makes [__] awkward yeah if
you're if you're not getting if you're
not kidling with 20 of your friends man
you don't want to be funny at work you
should say that for the stage hey I've
had that's happened where I've invited
co-workers to a show and then a comedy
come a comedian comes up like oh he's
funny and then he wasn't I was like [__]
my bad oh yeah that would have been me
last night we all came out to see you do
why didn't go Howe Mandel was there
that's what did you remember that I
heard that he was there but see him I
wonder if that's why I got kicked off
too cuz they were like all right we got
to have an air of professionalism get
this [__] drunker out here he went up
on the first show and you were there for
the allar show or the hopeing mik show
that's Russell's next show and I for the
10:00 or with hoe at with hoe at uh JFL
he's gonna do his um whatever they call
those things on his Gala JFL you're not
doing it this year or anything like that
was JFL the just for last oh no no I'm
not doing did you ask me if I was doing
the open mic show
no um no you were doing a show from from
somebody else had a show right on on on
Tuesday nights the college show right oh
yeah it was one of those like yeah yeah
I think it so what's so what's the
hardest job of being a personal
assistance besides driving the Bentley
from La besides driving the Bentley from
Los Angeles I should have came in one of
his cars up the Bley and driving back oh
looking forward to seeing you last week
bro be real was yeah that's dope man and
that's that's one of the times where I
got to drive Russell and Paula to pick
you up to go to BS uh podcast and [__]
broke down in front of my house in front
of his house so funny oh my God badass
64 Impala man badass 64 impo [__] didn't
work saw you in GL like hours later oh
yeah I was getting towed huh yeah people
passed by nice car doesn't
work the hardest the hardest thing is
that my life revolves around him right
now it's a little different thing too I
um I live with him [__] it's like Lisa
right but you know what I mean it's
tough right cuz you got to like you got
to like know this person's you got it's
not just booking a plane now like
anybody could book a plane for a
different type of people but when you
know the person you got to know exactly
like what seed because you know the
Personality yeah and I'm on top of it
for most of the time but but it's a
little [__] that bothers them like
there's no bread in the house like what
the [__] there's no bread that's like
[__] I didn't check the cabinet my bad
we're low on Peanut Butter like you forg
tennis shoes but you know what that's a
good thing if that's the if that's the
[__] I'm [__] up on as long as it's
not nothing huge right like for getting
a book of flight and he's at the airport
and he's like what the [__] you forget
to do something important though uh no I
don't think so man you just got to be
really organized but it's it's just
timec consuming that's the main thing I
would feel so sorry if I know Ivan G is
he still with I think he is his biggest
thing that ever that he did when I was
there Gabriel recording his one hour
over and over and Gabriel left the tapes
no Ivan left a little disc behind
Dam did he get in trouble yeah yeah
that's big you should have see him on he
was on a phone like two hours trying to
get the hotel room trying to get the
tapes trying to get trying to get some
ohoi to go over there and ask trying to
get anybody you know I only almost got
fired once and it was over a girl like a
[__] groupy where you know he was
[__] around with her this this was
like the first year I was with him and
um he's like don't [__] with this girl
she's [__] crazy and uh of course I
invited her over to the house [__] and
he took pictures she took pictures of of
his cars and of the house put it all
over her Facebook and he he checks my
Facebook and he's like what the [__] and
this was like two days before going to
Asia and he's like don't [__] come to
Asia get your [__] out of the house I
don't want to see you again his brother
calls me the next day he's like it's too
late for you not to come to Asia but uh
he's going to do you have to come but
he's going to downgrade you the economy
he you know he flies he flies his first
class everywhere we go dope my God but
since it was last minute it was a middle
seat 13 hour flight oh and uh it was
really awkward when I saw him you I had
to apologize and that was a [__] up but
hey it was a [__] up over a [__]
groupy like a girl that I tried [__]
around with after and uh that's what got
me in trouble but that's the the one
time that I almost got fired it's it's
weird like when you hang out with
Russell like he bought me three watches
yeah I lost one at um at the club at the
vental comedy club bro to go take a [__]
came back watch is gone damn damn dude
yeah so um like from The Green Room or
damn I've never gotten that opener
experience you know what I'm saying
where I've never the closest I got I
opened for Mia for like a few weeks
that's the closest I got to like where
you you know you hear the stories like a
bu people bu watching this [__]
Russell's a very generous guy man very
generous you know what's dope is even
before working for him I've never heard
people say bad things about him he's one
of those Comics that yeah he's one of
those Comics that takes care of everyone
pays openers more than most comics and
he's just a really generous guy takes
care of all his people so it's so nice
so who is he Roofing no right and you
know what and he's one of the few Comics
that that has never been on drugs he
didn't drink his first alcoholic
beverage until he was 31 years old
that's interesting so you know I think I
remember when I first started working
with him my mom was scared thinking I
was going to get into the ENT his story
his story start like this I remember
everything that happened yeah he's got a
great memory I was a he I went to a
store with him in um Toronto right at
the mall and they were following this
[__] like TMZ like um they were
following him bro like a bunch of people
he had to to put a hat on and hide so we
went to the store bro and I'm checking
out these boots right the store is
called Davids I never heard of [__]
Davids and um he's buying boots and um
he goes hey Filipe you like those boots
fool yeah they're all right you know I I
did like them they're all right go you
want them and I said Noah I'm good man
and I saw I saw the price yeah
$1,300 damn and I said they're $1,300
I'm good bro I can't pull this
off if I tell somebody somebody bought
them for me they're going to say what
$200 they're going to believe that [__]
now if I tell them I stole them and
they're worth 200 I could get away with
that that's awesome nobody 1300 boo
Dustin you need that roll I was thinking
that I'm like that would be the only
thing on my purse in this worth anything
you know I got a shitty t-shirt on with
nice
boots Dustin the win
podcast what you
fat what you want fat ass people like
that bro sh bring Dustin back we did
what you want F hey how many how many
shows is this for you with uh it's like
three yeah oh number three yeah but
we're also working on a pilot so for a
sitcom that's actually which is weird
that's how we mostly met yeah so how's
that going good good brother I run into
him when he was clean cut when he first
got here when I was a good boy were you
where you from are you from Texas from
Dallas Dallas but I moved here from New
York I moved from Dallas to New York to
uh
here yeah yeah man so what you got going
on next bro where you going to man we're
chilling most of the summer Russell's
working on a movie right now so Orleans
so I got the house to
myself you got a PO let me come over got
a pool man got a you going be next
Tuesday yeah come by go bodyboarding by
your house let do it man yeah so I got I
got the house to myself bring Isaac
Hayes he had those summer free that day
yeah he could go swimming at the house
man Isaac he'll have fun yeah we'll make
some vegan Burgers bro bring bring your
bunny yeah I've known I knew you since
you were a
carnivore since you're a carniv I don't
we'll bring it we'll do some I'll tell
Rodrigo to come yeah you should come too
if you mind yeah you go bring whoever
bring my girlfriend Russell says bring
whoever bring your girlfriend what I say
it's a dude thing
bring I'll bring a t too so yeah man
we'll make some vegan taco bro you can
[__] take a big ass bite again yeah
Lisa I want to try some of your Vegan
Cooking for sure we'll do it I want to
try
saiche
saiche hopefully uh we're going to we're
going taking a break from the what food
podcast but what I'm think I'm going to
do is um hopefully record three podcasts
at one day oh there you go and then be
gone for three weeks we have aing issue
next week we have a scheduling issue
next week maybe the next week good
problem to have we might be off for two
weeks might be off for two weeks people
damn what's up fol thank you very much
to our Our Guest Eddie chilling here
pleasure and honor thank you V hell yeah
man Ed been a fan since day since I can
remember so thanks for hooking up that
checking account still yeah man Dustin
iara you have a lot of apologizing to do
tomorrow hey I got done with my
apologizing early all right the next
step is uh let's start talking [__] but
I got to find a comic that I just hate
and just start some [__] with this
[__] bring back the p with Nick
man about the [__] dtin the wind
podcast I sure I should be like listen I
know you said sorry but I'm I got I'm
not done with this I know you said sorry
but you trying to [__] with me ah and
now I'm going to [__] with you [__] I'll
put gum in your
hair run
everything what's up
fool go SN catched the mic off his hand
stage